is the ability to switch on and off a
personal feature or is it a trained
skill is this confused with the term
beast mode what causes that switch to
flip the overdrive the beast mode the
full-on destroyer that will not stop I
think it's actually this is it is
something that's learned I think and I
think it's a hard lesson I don't think
everyone gets it I think some people go
through life without ever getting it and
I'll tell you it's it's an important
lesson nature it's critical lesson it's
the thing that allows you to go the
extra distance to dig just a little bit
deeper and push a little harder to get
after it
and like many other things in life
there's a dichotomy because it actually
takes in my opinion two opposing forces
to bring it to life it takes both
emotion and logic for you to reach your
match maximum potential to to really
give everything you have and go beyond
your limits
because both emotion and logic they're
gonna reach their limitations and when
one fails you need to rely on the other
one so when it doesn't make sense
logical sense to go on that's when you
got to use your emotion that's when you
gotta use that anger and that
frustration that fear to push yourself
hard
to push yourself to say I don't stop and
when your feelings are screaming that
you've had enough and when you think
you're gonna break emotionally you got
to override that emotion with the
concrete logic and willpower that says
you know what I don't stop so you you
fight the weak emotions with the power
of logic and you fight the weakness of
logic with the power of emotions and in
the balance of those two that's where
you find the strength and the tenacity
and the guts to say yourself I don't
stop and you won't